what is it like three inches or
something so it's like this this much I
was close really close Butler has no
time outs three its hey we're pulling it
down to getting around so that one
watches the shot is the king of the
dance 2010 Butler in this position for
the first time ever taking on mighty
Duke whose dream will come true tonight
I asked our guys at the practice three
days before I said hey there's a large
contingent of people that have asked me
are you interested in measuring the rims
and measuring the free throw line like
the movie Hoosiers and our guys said
hell no people said it was a Cinderella
story and in our eyes we didn't picture
it like that at all Butler was as good
as any team in the country they were
physical they were confident they were
aggressive we came into the national
title game expecting to win that year
you had this unbelievably mature team
who had been through the wars together
we were at our highest level of play the
entire season we walked in to that
national championship game with a lot of
swagger
it was everything you wouldn't want a
championship game to be how could you
not like to watch that
it felt like it was going to be a game
that came down to the last possession
pretty much throughout the second half
you expect to get to that point where
five four minutes are left in the game
and you start to pull ahead it was a
game we should have worn by eight ten
points the game kind of goes back and
forth
we cut a five-point lead 2-1 building up
to a last shot opportunity 15 seconds
mat-su back to flexing
stays with bunker with thirteen point
six seconds Bunder had the ball with an
opportunity to take the lead on an
inbounds play with about 13 seconds left
on the clock okay here we go
angle detail has to call the timeout as
a coach you never want to use your final
timeout until you know it's the very
last possession Butler has no timeouts
it's going to be Howard instead of
Heyward well gives Heyward a chance to
be involved and maybe screening and
catching the past well there it is out
to Heyward cut it right here
and I was told just to make a play I
like going left more than anything so I
tried to go this way
same worth defending ten seconds ago he
wants to drive and coming up and I went
behind the back and drove behind the
back the whole time I knew I'm gonna
shoot this and zubik pops out right here
I was able to use my height all 72 of me
and actually affect the play in a
positive way on the baseline makes me
step back but I arc it a little bit more
than I normally would
three point six seconds you know I
missed it that walk back to the other
free-throw line was one of the longest
walks I've ever experienced now sit back
put the line to a couple dribbles made
the first one about the shoot the second
one and briefly look over and let's get
the signal to miss it says missing
Coach K elected to have him miss the
second one to not give Butler a chance
to run a set plate it is a risk right
because then it stays a two-point game
missing that free-throw though does put
a lot of pressure on you to get the ball
up the court quickly you don't win
something big without taking some risk
you just don't want it to be Gamble's
I didn't gamble I wrist Heyward had
already made a game-winner in this state
high school championship game and had
already proven to be an outstanding
clutch player in this situation let's
see what they got lined up here you know
we're down 12.1 seconds left and you
know we have to go the length of the
court I like to get the ball thingy work
somehow
honestly I was definitely back of my
mind this very similar situation with
the chance to win national title game in
Indianapolis
I can definitely remember thinking here
we go again let's do it again
that young man right there at a Milan
moment do you believe in sequels
certainly looks that way better partner
my goodness we've always put Gordon in a
position that he would be our most
likely to rebound so you knew that our
best player was going to get the ball
again he misses the free throw
and from then it's playing off natural
instincts the tape were pulling it down
did I get the ball right here and he
kind of falls into me I bodied him up
for about a second to a second off the
clock getting around shoot back I end up
dribbling it out this way this is
singular and he kind of steps up and
picks me up
Matt Howard comes in and sets a big time
screen from right here
it allows me to kind of get around him
and end up shooting the shot right
around here it's like when you're a kid
and you're in a gym and you're counting
down you're like three two one and you
just throw up the ball and try to try to
make the shot I'm gonna try it's a word
pulling it down getting it round so that
at midcourt
it's the king of the dance 2010 it
really did feel good on my hands off my
fingertips from our angle that ball
looked like it was going in
if it goes in I'm gonna be killed it was
pretty damn close and it was right there
I missed the shot so that's what
happened I can remember immediately
thinking about the shot before the half
court heave and thinking and that was
the shot I wish I could have that one
back ironically last year when we're
playing the Jazz he hits the shot the
exact same shot
hey we defended by Bradley Heywood gets
a little daylight Haywood a jumper nails
at 1.7 on the clock and literally came
in my office right after the game and so
that's a shot I've missed against Duke I
told him I'd rather hit the one in the
championship instead of that one so we
had a good laugh about that but yeah
that's the shot that I hit all the time
you know our best player had the ball
and everybody you know can live with
that result
if it goes in and it'll go down as the
greatest shot in the history of
basketball the shot goes in you know and
you're asking me where Butler would rank
in terms of all-time underdog teams
everybody else has to be the judge of
that because to us we were supposed to
win